I love this idea of the dueling junket
so tell me why are the Brits better uh
well I'm obviously very biased it's
small but I'm better than twine it's a
you know it's an idea and I think they
wanted to keep the tension between me
and me and the big man so I'm sure we'll
be saying a few derogatory things about
each other as we go along the day how
bad you get because now that I've seen
it and saw what all went into it you
know what it's uh we sort get used to it
these kind of action sequences that we
do we try and do as much practical stuff
as we can so we love to do it in camera
and one of the benefits we have is we
have a very very proficient director
called David Lee she was an old stunt
guy what is your body like after a day
of shooting how bumped bruised up and
did you really get uh you know it's uh
it's hard to predict what comes your way
you know we if I refer to the apartment
fight you know so we confined space
saucepans are flying around its toasters
getting hit in the head and it's there's
a lot of adrenaline fueled commotion
uh-huh and we try and be accurate and we
try and get the distances but at times
because of the adrenaline you go a
little bit further and yeah something
always someone gets clocked someone
twists their back someone does something
a lot of the time it's the poor old
stuntmen the the ones that because they
have to hit the you know hit the counter
and they have to smash into the window
and they have to have a real sort of
loose body and they're the ones that you
know they take the biggest brunt so we
can never bow we have to keep our mouths
shut because they're the ones that now I
know sometimes directors will balk when
the stars want to do a lot of their own
stunts how much did you get away with or
how much did you want to do did you did
you want to go balls to the wall well
yes we do more what they called a
physical action okay the the skill set
that we can
to hone down in the gym is what we try
and exploit on camera so anything that
has a hard hit what we call real stunt
work that has real you know real danger
to it we leave to the pros that can take
those hits and so we try and figure out
you know this we tried to elevate some
of the skill sets that we work on in the
gym and we try and put that on on camera
so we do a lot of training with we work
for you know I've done this for years
now
so we like to shoot things practical and
I know Dave I've known Dave for many
years and he comes from a martial arts
background and he's got so do you right
yeah yeah I've trained at Dave's gym for
you know a good 12 15 years him and Chad
and I've you know I've worked on prep
for movies over there they've shot
second unit on my movies we've done
stunt coordination on my movie I've
thrown I've had a fight scene on camera
with Dave in a movie I did called the
mechanic and I'll sent him through this
semi flying through earth through a bus
window so we're really old pals really
and he knows my skill set and he knows
what he wants for his movie and we were
living good we're in a good place when
we when we when we're in need to do good
action now you're a martial artist
you're like elusive and you you can move
quick Swain is in the gym and he's big
and brawny so my question is in a real
fight who do you think will win and I'm
telling you I've added everybody and
you'd be surprised at the answers you'd
have to get him when he's looking over
me gets you in his hip you know because
you in his Carribean you're dead mate
Helen said speak away on my side no
against me Helen Helen said speed Helen
said speed wins you know it is an old
thing it's like a you know Bruce Lee was
130 pounds he was he could move quick he
could hit people accurately and I think
we see in the UFC and we've seen it in
you know in the early days of the UFC we
see hoist Gracie come in and he was a
slim guy and he applied incredible
technique and overcome some obstacles of
human you know these kind of mountains
of the men
would come in and literally get choked
out so this there's always a technique
you see big guys that look like they
could pick up a truck yeah and they get
hit on the chin and they you know the
lights go and sleep it's it's quiet
that's the interesting part of them
about the the mixed martial arts world
is you see the practical elements really
come out on what is really efficiently
used and what works and what doesn't
work is so my favorite pastime is to
what mixed martial arts I love it so
much I think that they are the ultimate
sort of badasses no we should pretend to
be what what they do for real ok well if
they're the ultimate badasses that's
true but in Hollywood like you and Duane
are kind of like the toughest badasses
in Hollywood right now that we're seeing
it's true
just take that compliment put in your
pocket take your foot in your pocket
wait okay a couple things about you guys
which one of you guys goes hardest in
the gym
well look we can clearly see the results
of that is you know if you're talking
about weight stacks you know and leg
presses and you mean Dwayne is but your
workout might be different because it's
like we're trying to I think what we try
and do listen for the sake of this movie
you know Shaw's a guy you know you drink
a pint of beer Ariel be there and it's
tailored suit he doesn't want to get hot
and sweaty for no reason he wants to do
things efficiently he can use his head
and use you know a certain skillset to
the overcome a certain situation that's
his technique yeah yeah okay I wonder I
asked Vanessa this and she loved it
which one of y'all's head is shinier
it's a question for somebody else to
answer
we've I've got a bit of a reflective
diamond she said she saw a reflection in
both okay which one of you guys is the
bigger softie I think I know the answer
uh the biggest softie you know we're
both worse off yeah yeah I mean we're
both dad's so I think when we're in a
sort of family environment we get you
know
we got to make silly faces and be a big
pushover you like a big hug and a big
smooch absolutely yeah all right what's
one of y'all's the biggest diva the
biggest diva most demands biggest diva
well you know he's not here so I'm gonna
say it's clearly the big man himself he
likes his you know he likes his food to
come in which one of you are or what's
an embarrassing thing about Dwayne that
we may not know you might not know he
you know he's he's afraid of heights he
gets motion sickness so when we was in
the McLaren you know that's a car it
does go above 30 miles an hour the
reason he drives those big trucks is
because they're quite slow so when he
was in the McLaren he had to say it cut
the motion sickness pills before he
became a true thing now um we saw at the
premiere I saw you and your lady she
looked amazing the member Saachi dress
hello Oh easy how big of a fast and
furious fan and Rosie or has she just
like come on with you you'd have to ask
her I'm not sure I mean she likes ya she
likes a lot of different types of movies
you know I don't think she's dragging
her friends stick I mean she did she
thought the movie was great she really
did yeah but my fella was like kickin it
like you were kicking me in their movie
I'd be like you know they get this movie
really it's hard not to enjoy this no
matter what your flavor is it's got a
lot of feel-good moments it's got some
great comedies if some two of the best
cameos I've seen in movies for for a
long long time
eggs are everything yes movies I mention
in those two chaps
they are literally bring the house down
moments pressure so it you'd have to be
really miserable not to enjoy this film
[Music]
[Applause]